hi everyone
my name is gustavo flores and i'm a
customer engineer here at google cloud
and i am daniel also a custom engineer
at google cloud
welcome back to the google cloud
technical guides for startups
where we're creating a series of videos
for technical enablement to help
startups to start
build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on google
cloud
in our previous episode we've shared
with you how you can get started with
compute on google kubernetes engine
today we're moving on to compute with
google compute engine
we're going to kick off by covering
what is compute engine following that
i'll be going over some common compute
engine configuration you may want to
modify
then we'll have a demo of compute engine
where we'll do the following
show source code in cloud shell
create an instance template for your
instances
create a managed instance group for your
template
deploy an application to the instances
running on the manage instance group
and put a low balancer in front of the
group so that we can access the
application
now we're going to review a customer
success story
so what is google compute engine
compute engine is
an intuitive
and flexible
simple at scale
and secure compute service that
lets you create and run your
applications on google cloud's global
infrastructure
let's talk flexibility
there are six different vm families
three within the general purpose and
three that are optimized for specific
types of workloads
general purpose vms are ideal for a wide
variety of applications like web serving
databases and image processing
and common flavors optimized for either
cost or a balance of price and
performance
workload optimized vms include compute
memory and accelerator optimized options
for your most demanding applications
such as sap hana and high performance
computing
you can achieve even greater savings
through taking advantage of spot vms
spa vms are affordable compute instances
suitable for batch jobs and fault
tolerant workloads google cloud spot vms
guarantee higher minimum savings and
more predictability and pricing for spot
instances compared to other cloud
providers
let's talk security
google cloud and compute engine are
designed to be secured by default
for enhanced security you can leverage
shielded vms
sure the vm features include
verifiable integrity with secure and
measured boot
secure boot helps prevent malicious code
from being loaded early in the boot
sequence
measure boot ensures the integrity of
the bootloader and kernel and boot
drivers to guard against malicious
modifications to the vm
vtpm exfiltration resistance you can
validate your guest vm pre-boot and boot
integrity using vtpn technology which is
compatible with trusted computing group
tpm 2.0 specifications
trusted uefi firmware trusted firmware
is based on the unified extensible
firmware interface or uefi
2.3.1
which replaces legacy bios subsystems
and enables uefi secure boot capability
tamper evident attestations
gain insight into the integrity state of
should the vms
with tamper evident attestation claims
available in cloud logging and cloud
monitoring
these integrity measurements help
identify changes from the healthy
baseline of your vm and current runtime
state
live migration and patching
keep your virtual machines instances
running even when a host system event
occurs such as software or hardware
updates you can define iem policies and
permissions you can set these policies
and permissions that constrain all new
compute engine instances to you should
the vm disk images and have vpn and
integrity monitoring options enabled you
can shield existing vm images too
transform your existing vms into
shielded vms that run on google cloud
bringing verifiable integrity and
exfiltration resistance to your existing
images
with google compute engine and cloud tpu
sensing delivers highly scalable sas ai
based solutions across the globe
sentence platform analyzes and fuses
data from different iot devices to
deliver insights across multiple
industries
they said
with compute engine and cloud tpu
sensing can spin up vms and configure
tpu clusters on demand with minimal
effort
and expanding capacity or extending
functionality is fast and easy
i am going to demonstrate how to create
a compute engine manage instance group
to deploy a simple web application
docker will be used to build the
container images and deploy them in our
virtual machines
we're also going to expose our
application to the internet by using an
external http load balancer
our sample application is a simple
guestbook where visitors can submit
messages and clear them we can perform
these steps by both using the google
cloud sdk in the cloud shell or using
the google cloud console
before we get to deploy our app i will
use cloud shell to clone the github repo
and use the text editor to show you the
code
you can find the link to the github repo
in the video description if you want to
follow along
let's click the activate cloud shell
button at the top of the google cloud
console
and we see the cloud shell section open
inside a new frame at the bottom of the
console and display a command line
prompt
let's use this terminal to enter the get
clone command and clone the repo
cloud shell comes with a built-in code
editor that we'll use to read the code
launch the cloud shell editor by
clicking the code editor button on the
toolbar of the cloud shelf window
now let's use the left hand pane to
navigate to the code by clicking on the
cpu 100 folder
then app folder and select the app.pi
file
as you can see in this python script
flask is used for handling http requests
for publishing and clearing messages and
redis is used to save the entries
we also have a docker file containing
all the commands to create the images
that will be used to run our docker
container
i am now going to show you how to create
an instance template
instance templates are a convenient way
to save a virtual machine's instance
configuration so you can use it later to
create a virtual machine or a group of
virtual machines
let's navigate to compute engine using
the left hand pane and click instance
templates
click create instance template
and it is now time to enter our desired
configuration
let's give it a simple name
guestbook server
under the machine configuration section
we can see virtual machines are
classified by machine family series and
machine types
for our application let's select the
general purpose e2 medium
which we can see has two vcpus and four
gigs of memory
under the boot this section we can click
the change button to select the
operating system in its version and the
disk type and size we want for our
virtual machines
let's add our startup script which will
install docker
build the image
deploy the container
and expose it internally
our individual machines don't need an
external ip because we will expose the
app to the internet using a load
balancer
so let's specify none as the external ip
and finally let's click create
now that we have our template
let's use it to create a managed
instance group
manage instance groups lets you operate
apps on multiple identical vms and make
your workload scalable and highly
available
you can take advantage of automated
services including auto scaling auto
healing multiple zone deployment and
automatic updating
from the instance templates section
expand the action menu next to the
guestbook server template
and click the create instance group
button
we now see the configuration options for
a group of vms
let's give this group a simple name like
guestbook server mid
and we can now decide if we want our vms
to be deployed in one or multiple zones
we will keep this in the us central one
a zone
notice we can configure the auto scaling
mode and policy a minimum and maximum
number of vms
auto scaling metrics auto healing and
other aspects of our managed instance
group
let's go ahead and click create
now if we navigate to the vm instances
menu
we're able to see all the individual
machines that are part of our management
group
let's go ahead and check that docker is
running correctly via ssh
click ssh under the connect column
corresponding to the only instance in a
group in the instances list
to ssh in a new window
we'll use the command
sudo
systemctl
status docker
in the resulting output we can see the
container engine is active and running
our container as intended
before creating our load balancer we
need to create an ingress firewall rule
applicable to the group of vms being
load balanced to allow health checks
let's use cloud shell to create this
rule
notice the two source ip ranges and
protocol needed to allow health checks
now let's create a configuration by
selecting the backend services input box
and click the create a back-end service
button
let's give it the name
guestbook back-end
and let's choose
guest book server mig instance group as
our backend
enter 80 for the port number
our backend requires us to create a
health check so traffic is only directed
to healthy machines so let's select the
health check input box and click the
create l check
i will name this
basic http health check
and leave the default values
select our newly created health check
and click create
now let's review the front-end default
configuration
and we can see the protocol will be http
and a female ipv4 ip address will be
assigned
and port 80 will be used
everything looks good
so we can click on the create button
let's review some of our load balancer
details by clicking on the guestbook
http lb
in the load balancers list
and we're now able to use this ip
address to use the web application
running in our manage instance group
let's use the browser to visit the
application by copying and pasting the
ip address and port in the address bar
and here it is our simple guestbook
application
now let's leave a short message in our
guestbook
hello
google cloud
and we're set
we deployed our guesswork application to
a manchester's group and exposed it
using a load balancer
and if after the session you cannot get
enough of compute engine and are keen to
find out more
check out the suggestions here and the
links in the description box below
you can read up on compute engine
you can check out the google cloud
drawing board on compute engine
or you can try our quick labs on compute
engine in our next episode you'll be
learning about google cloud's global
network it will cover vpc networking
firewall rules
load balancers a demo where we'll
configure the network for the booking
application you saw earlier finally
another customer success story
thank you and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]